[Applause]
[Music]
thank you laura and
tom you have not only played a role
in some of the most memorable films i've
worked on
but you played a role literally in why i
love this work
and why i have the privilege of being
among
tonight's honorees especially my
longtime
colleagues and friends kathy and frank
and the people in this room thank you
to my family to the love of my life
my wife carol
[Applause]
and and sue and doug and cindy brian
skyler and danny thank you academy
governors
i like like that song in hamilton
you were in the room where it happened
it's in the room where it happens
i find it hard to believe this is
actually happening
this oscar has been the most surprising
and exciting award i can imagine
we've had three presidents of the
academy dick khan
sid ganes and cheryl boone isaacs
from our own public relations branch but
this is the first time the academy is
considered
one of us for this award so that makes
it
the most humbling honor to
it certainly makes me think of all the
mentors
and bosses who have inspired me
along the way the head of marketing at
mgm
howard dietz who wrote lyrics for
broadway and film musicals on
mgm letterhead a lyricist
and the publicist imagine that
and tex mccreary he
arranged to take over madison square
garden
for a big rally with 20 000 people
singing and shouting and screaming i
like ike
we he had america's most famous pilot of
the time
a woman jackie cochran and she
took the film of the event and flew it
to eisenhower in france
to convince him to run for president
and in 1963 along with
others i played a small but personal
role
in organizing the celebrity
activists from bert lancaster sydney
partier harry belafonte
and dozens of others to go to the march
on washington
when it comes to politics celebrity
is a controversial word right now but
that's what we do
we we use celebrity to fight for civil
rights
and i'm
i'm proud to see that passion still
shared today
i learned a lot from tax and howard
particularly that all of this is great
but that is also has to be about showing
up for someone
good it has to be good it has to have
a purpose and the person
who most taught me about that
more than anyone else is steven
spielberg
yeah you bet
he's always treated me like a
storyteller
and we are all storytellers in the
public relations branch
because the universe we build around
around our films and our tv
isn't just about the story being told
but it's about making sure that the
story lasts
sure it's about making sure that people
come to the theater
but it doesn't stop there we have to ask
will they be moved by this and sometimes
maybe they look for something that they
miss
for the first time something worth
taking a second look at
and maybe learning from it
i like that the description of my work
of our work is in this branch
because when stephen
created the showa foundation after
schindler's list
we were doing exactly that we wanted to
make sure
the voices and the stories of countless
survivors
of the genocide and those who are no
longer with us
live on loudly at last
and it wasn't just just in the
in the months and years after the films
released
for generations to come to lead
to learn the horrors
of history
[Applause]
and with the starlight children's
foundation stephen is
a chairman emeritus i'm proud to be on
the board of directors
of something that creates moments of joy
and comfort
to hospitalize children because that too
is helping children
write their own story
this oscar is such an incredible honor
and i know a lot of people wrote and
supported me
and i want to say how much that means to
me
of course i remember feeling that way
about a letter that one other time in my
life
that actually was a recommendation
letter
tex had given to me
he he wrote quote marvin
is married to a girl who is as sharp as
he is
and guarantees that you'll get two
brains
for the higher of one and that terrific
he was right carol is still enjoying her
own career
while i have been enjoying mine of
course
she always knew what my job entailed
but most friends and relations outside
the industry
really had no clue so i never could
explain
the full range of what the job really
entails
but at least now they know
i got an oscar for it thank you